[Music]
my name is Manish Alice Ani I am a
product manager here with the Google
cloud networking team and I also have
with me here Greg who manages UI teams
for us
Aaron Emma who leads us research for us
and Jason who's a customer of ours from
pivot first of all some logistics number
one no snoring and number two as we go
through the presentation you can go to
the next app click on the Dory Q&A and
you can ask us questions as we go
through the presentation Dory is just an
internal Q&A app that we have to be able
to manage all of your questions at scale
and we can kind of get back to you even
after the session ends in case you're
not able to get to your question so we
will go through these questions and
we're also take live questions at the
end so over the past few years we've
been talking to a lot of our customers
around how they manage their cloud
network what are the key key pain points
how exactly do their workflows look like
and where they spend a significant
amount of time while they're
troubleshooting issues and based on this
we've been building a suite of products
so we thought what we could do today is
actually talk through the top issues
that emerge based upon those
conversations introduce a few of the
products that we've built based on that
and also walk through exactly how you
can use those products to be able to
solve those top pain pine points that we
identified and you'll also hear from
Jason here around how he thinks about
solving these use cases at pivot as an
additional its perspective so thanks to
all of you who have spent a significant
amount of time with us in one-on-one
settings and workshops providing
feedback to us as we built our products
and iterated on them so here's what we
heard from you overall I would say we
could categorize these issues that we
you brought up into three broad
categories the first one was network
connectivity issues so think of it as
everything from a broad question around
I want to know all that's there on my
network and what talks to what all the
way to very granular questions on how
can I resolve connectivity issues to a
specific port or my VM the second
category of issues that emerged was
around network troubleshooting so when
an issue comes in you want to be able to
very quickly understand if this is a
network issue number one and number two
then be able to very quickly isolate the
problem itself where it lies within the
network you also told us that you wanted
us to be more proactive and letting you
know when some of your metrics like
bandwidth or latency are beyond the norm
for what's average for your network the
third set of issues that emerge were
around network security
so these southern examples around this
category were things like you want to
understand all the firewall rules
associated with a VM instance going to
very quickly understanding if there was
a very specific firewall rule that was
causing problems for you and also
identifying who might have changed
certain rules our touch certain rules in
your network so based upon those top
concerns that I talked about right now I
want to talk to you about four specific
products I'll introduce the products and
my colleague Greg will do a deep dive on
them
the first one is network interface
details so network interface details
gives you a vm's view of the network you
can in a single page see the key
attributes for that VM instance and the
network interface you can also view all
the firewall rules associated with that
specific VM instance and the effect that
those firewall rules have on that VM
instance
so that should allow you to very quickly
diagnose network connectivity issues and
also verify if only the intended ports
and protocols are accessible for that
specific VM instance the second product
is VP seafloor logs so vbc flu logs
provide responsive flow level network
telemetry for your GCP environment think
of it as analogous to our net flow for
those of you used to that VPC flow logs
provides near real-time telemetry
without having any performance impact to
you so it also provides a granularity
that you might be comfortable with you
should be able to collect metrics for
say a V PC network or a subnet or drill
all the way down to be able to collect
metrics around a specific VM instance or
a virtual interface and it includes
metrics like a through port and RTT the
next product I want to talk to you about
is firewall logs so firewall logs get
you visibility into every single
connection attempt against a specific
firewall rule that you have logging
enabled for so you should be able to see
an audit all the connections that were
allowed and those that failed and you
should be able to take that information
and understand patterns press perform
some real-time analysis as well as be
able to kind of ship it off to Google
Cloud Storage for future forensics and
audit use cases and the last one the
fourth one I want to talk to you about
was load balancer telemetry so this
monitoring provides you visibility into
all of your internet facing applications
you get metrics and visibility for both
the front end and the back end and it
includes metrics like number of requests
a latency again for the front end and
the back end and the connections that
were open that failed as well as
throughput so we talked about
network interface details EPC floral
logs five all logs and load balancer
telemetry and with that I will pass it
over to Greg for a deep dive and demo of
all of these thank you
alright thanks Vanessa
so as Manasa mentioned rather than going
through the features themselves I
thought we would go through a couple of
demos that showcase how we can use the
tools that Manasseh was talking about in
order to deal with real life problems
right huh sorry can we go back to the
slides yes thank you okay so I wanted to
again go some through some practical use
cases and things that you encounter on a
day to day basis one of the things that
we realized when we were doing our
research and we were looking at the
problems you encounter is that you
encounter a very difficult or tricky
problem once in a while the rest of it
is death by a thousand cuts alright so
the typical use cases that that we find
people struggling with are very basic
things like connectivity so let's go
through use case number one imagine you
are back in engineer who's decided to
use a new database for your project
you're developing you locally and
everything works just fine now you're
ready to stand up a test environment you
create an instance to run your app you
create an instance to run the database
server you start the app and it Hanks
right of course it's like Friday
afternoon you've been working all day to
do it it's 4:30 you're ready to go home
meet somebody hang out unfortunately
it's not working so let's go to the demo
and talk about how we can resolve or
troubleshoot what's going on okay so I'm
the developer I'm happy I've set up my
entire environment here's the IP address
I'm ready to go I hit enter and it's
hanging okay it might still be oh oh no
I never has occurred okay what do we do
now so if you are a network admin you
are sure it's an application issue and
if you're a developer you're sure it's a
network issue all right that is one
thing that's a fact so the developer who
probably at this point start looking at
application logs trying to figure out
what's going on and the root cause of
the time delays here are mostly because
we don't know where the problem is all
right so we don't know if it's a network
problem yet but if we can rule out the
network that gives us a really good hint
of where we can go looking next so let's
see how we can use the network interface
Paige in order to rule out any possible
issues with the network or to prove that
there are issues with the network so
this is my GCP project here's a web
server here's the my sequel server
ignore the suspicious toast for now
there's nothing going on there I will
look at that one later okay so the web
server is here this is what I'm
connecting to and the database server is
here so let's click on these three dots
on the side and right here there's
something it says view network details
first I'll give you a quick overview of
what the page contains and then I'll
show you how you use it the top part are
the attributes that Manasseh was talking
about these are things that we found
were sprinkled through the console
everywhere they're on the details page
some of these things were varied in sub
tabs on the on the network on the
instance details page it was very hard
to pull all this together so just by
pulling it all together we found that
we're adding a lot of value by showing
you the things that are the most
important to this instances behavior on
the network that it's on and beyond that
we looked at firewall rules and routes
so if you have a V PC network in
production you probably have hundreds of
firewall rules maybe even thousands if
you wanted to understand which firewall
rules were applying to this instance in
the past you would go to the firewalls
list page and go through all thousand of
them I'm not kidding
all thousand one by one decide which
ones apply which ones don't create a
list of those so we thought we can do
that better so we did that for you right
so these are the firewall rules that are
applying only to the specific instance
taking things like tags and other things
service accounts into account right we
do the same thing for routes so now we
have a list of firewall rules but that
still means you have to go through each
one of them and apply those firewall
rules in the order that the control or
the data plane actually applies them all
right so we took it a step further and
we created the network analysis section
this is what's here at the bottom so let
me explain what's going on here
it's not necessarily the easiest concept
so we are creating a two-dimensional
grid on one dimension we have all
possible ingress sources on the other
dimension we have all possible protocols
and ports we run through all of the
firewall rules one by one and then we
open and close port source combinations
and then we come up with a model a
two-dimensional model of what can access
this instance we do it for egress and we
do it for rounds as well after we do
that we dump all of that out into a
tabular form most
specific IP stoolie specific all right
so I happen to know the IP address of my
database server it's 1000 3 all right I
can check to see whether the database
server can access this instance actually
I'm not interested in that I'm
interested to see if this can access the
database server so I'll look at egress
and see hmm
this instance can access everything so
it's certainly not an outbound firewall
rule it could be an inbound firewall
rule on the database so let's go to the
same page on the database server all
right that was the web server here's a
database server the network details
scroll down to the analysis and find web
server has an IP address of 1000 five so
scrolling down here it is everything is
blocked except for these ports now it's
a my sequel database so if you know what
my sequel runs on is 3306 it's not there
it's missing that's the problem it's a
firewall rule I can go up here and find
oh man there is a firewall rule someone
did create it it's just disabled hmm so
I can click on the firewall rule edit it
turn it back on patiently wait
it's refreshed just in case
firewall rule is active I go to the
analysis and I see hmmm 3306 is now
allowed that looks good let's go back to
the error page refresh and it works I
know it's hard to read but it says it
works it's pretty happy in the corner
there alright so that was use case
number one let's go to use case number
two can we go back to the sides please
all right use case number two is about
network security so your network
security admin intercompany
your company has a process for auditing
all new sensitive systems like database
servers to ensure that access is limited
to what's absolutely necessary and
you're leading an audit for a new
database server right so the one we just
stood up in use case one you want to
verify obviously that only necessary
ports are open for the documentation of
the dev team you want to understand
what's connecting to that server and you
want to understand what your security
posture is blocking all right so if we
could go back to the demo I won't go
through the network details interface
the network interface details page again
but I think you can see how this would
be very helpful and understanding what
can and cannot access an instance let's
look at some things that actually show
what's happening alright so we talked
about VPC flow logs and firewall logs
earlier so this is actual information of
what's happening on the network every
single packet that's moving around your
network well not every single packet
every single flow is captured alright
and this is an example of a particular
flow all right so I've gone to the
stackdriver logging section in logs
I have VPC flow logs enabled I've hit
sub Network that's the resource that
this is on and then I look at VPC flows
here is one object that represents a
flow on that occurred on the network
you'll see some helpful information so
the five tuple is nicely located here
and then some annotations like the
destination instance and the destination
V PC so annotations that you can use
alright so this is an actual traffic on
the network we do the same thing for
firewalls and so every firewall rule
that has this enabled will generate logs
all right so here is a firewall rule
that denied a particular piece of
traffic we have information about the
instance we have information about the
connection again the 5-tuple so nice and
familiar right and then some information
about the firewall rule itself which
firewall rule it was what the action is
effectively metadata that's on the
firewall rule alright this is
interesting however there will be
thousands of these records and we're
obviously not going to go one
and look at what's going on all right so
you can take this two step further and
export this into bigquery and we're
really anything that this analysis I've
chosen bigquery for obvious reasons it
was easy it was a one-click option
operation when I did that all right I
constructed a query that will take all
source IP addresses the action of the
firewall rule and the reference as the
name of the firewall rule and the amount
of times that firewall rule was hit so
effectively creating a firewall hit
counter this is coming from the firewall
logs and I'm looking at things that are
specifically trying to access the my
sequel server we've been looking at
earlier a quick group by and then I
order by counts I hit run and we give it
a couple seconds and let's look at the
results actually I could just hide the
editor all right I instantly notice that
this IP address 1000 4 is being denied a
lot all right so today over 14 million
times so this instance the source IP
address is trying to access that
database server that we were looking at
earlier and that's a problem so I go
back and I take a look at what could
that possibly be and if you're paying
attention earlier you've guessed it that
is suspicious host all right now why is
this vicious host showing up here
because I'm running nmap from the
suspicious host against my sequel server
so we got that very very quickly we see
what's being blocked and we actually see
that some things are being success are
successfully passing through I could
augment this query and show things like
port information effectively anything
that was on the firewall logging record
from before all right
and one more use case so could we please
go back to the slides thank you use case
number three so we talked about internal
use cases a lot but let's say your
application goes to production so you've
put it behind an HTTP load balancer for
a lot of reasons what tools can you use
to monitor and gain visibility into that
traffic and so in this example let's
pretend you're a global e-commerce
company you're deployed in three regions
the US Europe and Asia and the site is
made up of different smaller
applications so it's pretty complicated
and if you've been to any of the load
balancing talks that we've had about
HTTP load balancer you know it's global
alright so we give you one IP address
customers connect to that one IP address
and it's routed to the resources that
are closer
that are closest to them so obviously if
you're in the US you want to be served
by US resources and the same thing with
Asia and Europe so how can we make sure
that's happening well let's go back to
the demo all right so here's a list of
load balancers that I have in this
project the one that we're talking about
shopping side lb I'll click on it
configuration is pretty complicated
there's brows back ends there's cards
there's a check out the something called
fees test HTTP and I'll go to monitoring
and in monitoring we see right away the
number of requests per second across the
back ends that are in this load balancer
if I look at a specific back-end let's
say brows I get this cool Sankey diagram
at the bottom and the Sankey diagram is
showing something very interesting
the locations here on the left hand side
are the entry points of traffic onto the
Google Network
alright so customers in North America
their traffic is entering in North
America and typically there are
resources that are configured for the
purpose of this demo I've taken them
down and as a result of that that
traffic is being automatically
distributed by the Google load balancing
infrastructure mostly to Europe and a
little bit to Asia the traffic
highlighted in yellow is effectively out
of region so it's being served out of
region and this is much higher latency
for you alright the customer has to go
all the way to Europe and the request
has come all the way back in order for
them to be served on top of this there's
a bunch of other load balancing metrics
that you can look at I won't go through
all of them I realize is probably hard
to read but we have things like latency
latency to the back-end latency to the
front-end in addition to things like
requests in throughput alright so those
are the three use cases I want to go
through could we please go back to the
slides and I'd love to ask our aneema to
come and join me or innama is a UX
researcher and she'll talk about some of
the research that we've done on this
topic thank you Greg
hi everyone as Greg mentioned I am Nima
and I am a UX research lead and me and
my team have been working with a lot of
you trying to understand you know some
of your challenges and pain points and
then bringing it back to our fabulous
p.m. and ang team to work iteratively
together so that we can fix some of
those problems and we through the last
couple of years have worked across amia
and us with our customers who are in
different verticals like finance retail
health gaming etc and also you know
we've been talking to network architects
cloud architects if you have not talked
to you yet please do stop by and we
would love to talk to you so that we can
get your feedback as well so as we were
trying to organize this discussion and
the stock we're thinking well there
might be many different ways of solving
the same problem and you might be like
at the end of Thursday or in the
beginning of Thursday towards the end of
the session board by just listening to
us giving demos or presenting so we
thought it might be interesting for you
to hear actually feedback from your own
peers as to how not only they are using
some of our tools but you know other
tools that they are using to solve those
problems so we thought that it might be
interesting for us to invite Jason
credit who is the senior director of
technology at pivot to come and talk to
us and talk through some of the use
cases welcome Jason so as runo my
mentioned I'm Jason kratom senior
director of technology to a company
called pivot you've likely never heard
of pivot and senior director of
technology may not tell you a lot about
what I do on a daily basis it's a little
ambiguous so I am the IT operations and
security guy we just have cool titles
for fancy so pivot is a oil and gas
engineering company predominantly we
focus on helping our customers transport
oil and gas and electricity from one
point to the other we start by
developing analytical solutions to help
plan where to build a physical asset in
the United States and
then how to transport it construct the
asset and then manage it and operate it
we are based I am based in Kansas City
so all of you San Franciscans we are not
Madison Bumgarner fans by any stretch of
the imagination but my dev team is
focused or lives in Denver Colorado and
then because we're so predominantly
focused in oil and gas we've got a large
Houston group as well that's pivot
that's great thank you so much Jason
before we go into some of the use cases
can I ask you why Google why now oh good
question you know we've um we started
our journey into the cloud around 2012
and we we really wanted to create an
application for people to use in our
industry that in in our industry oil and
gas and energy and utilities it's not
heavy IT by any means are you my users
are not heavy IT users so we we started
with Google Maps we wanted to make it
somewhat easy and familiar and and and
just sort of normal they're used to it
on their phones already so we wanted to
help them create clear fast and simple
intuitive interface and then we started
getting into that ecosystem we said well
Google Apps for Business makes a lot of
sense for us to store documents and
collaborate and then as we go through
time we started to just be immersed in
Google and and decided why not be in GCP
as well that's great so it looks like
you are using the whole ecosystem a lot
of it that's amazing so next Jason we
would like to talk through some of the
use cases and that greg demoed on and
see what and like understand your
perspective on them sounds great yeah
okay
so let's pretend that you are actually
working you know with a developer on
your team and who's developing a new
database and everything is working great
locally but as you are getting ready to
test in the environment and you create
an instance to run your app and then you
know the instance on the database and a
new instance as well what you see is
that your app is hanging
whatever happened to you yeah no there's
no reason to pretend this is this is a
normal day in my life and you know we
have great developers so if there's
developers here I'm sure you're great as
well but it always works on their
machine right always and yet when they
throw it over to my team to go and
implement in production or put it in the
into the cloud environment we notice
issues obviously and it doesn't just
work as we'd hope and it's Greg outlined
it's typically you know they're ready to
get out the door on a Friday afternoon
and then my team has to take it over to
implement into production or into a dev
or staging environment so this has
happened quite a bit recently we've been
transitioning I mentioned we started in
the cloud in 2012 we started
traditionally with a three-tier
architecture and now more recently we've
been moving to micro services as an
architecture and some server lists and
so there's a lot of volatility in our
environment right now and so through
that process every little piece we have
to take apart and deconstruct and then
start putting in to new environments and
when we've used docker and containerized
quite a bit of our application and what
happens is in a three-tier architecture
you've got kind of your border network
security defense and then you know each
tier your application and so forth has
has its own firewall rules and things
like that
you know in a micro services
architecture it's it's not quite like
that right you start to have millions
probably not but thousands of firewall
rules the that really define your
environment to find the security context
of your environment
and so when you run into this problem
and it's hanging you just got to scroll
through pages and pages and pages of
firewall rules and data to try to figure
it out and certainly there's tools out
there and we've got great documentation
like everybody does about our
environment how it should work however
you still need to solve the problem you
still need to go find the right rule to
change to modify it and because I own
networking and security it's it's my
team's role to go do that so
historically we would scroll through the
rules we'd search for IPs and things
like that to try to find our protocols
and it's difficult it was really really
difficult very time-consuming so with
the new tools like Greg mentioned with
network details now it's like two clicks
away right
so now we don't have to spend all this
time searching for it it's really quick
to see the instances view of its network
just like that it's amazing that the
natural details page is actually solving
some of your problems and so now you and
your dev can both have beer okay
so now that you know you and your dev
are having a very happy time let's move
on to the next use case so the next use
case here is let's pretend now that
you're working with your network
security admin and you are as Greg
mentioned doing an audit for a very
sensitive system and you wanted to
verify that all the necessary ports and
that the dev team has documented are
open and then understand what connecting
to the server and determine what
security posture is you know blocking
I'm sure you know with your passion in
security you have definitely faced some
of this as well can you talk to us no
question it we are very interested in
cyber security and in our industry
especially we're helping transport
critical infrastructure assets around
the u.s. and and so we care a lot about
protecting our customers privacy but
it's also interesting to think about our
customers are always comfortable with us
managing their data in the cloud
so we've got to an extra burden on us to
help show how we're protecting it in
four years in the cloud it was really
easy to sort of say yeah they we trust
our cloud provider to protect it we've
blocked for 22 the world so we're good
right and then we had auditors come in
and auditors or also sometimes if
they're here I apologize but not always
as technically savvy as they go through
a network infrastructure in the cloud
versus when we used to do it on Prem and
so we run into these two insas issues
where we've got to not only show port
22s be locked from the world but we've
got to prove it in some capacity and
forever in the cloud you could define
the firewall rules and they were set and
you're like see we're good right
22s blocked but
you want to prove it and you want to
prove it's been like that for some
amount of time now with firewall logging
you can start to go and look and see
improve nope absolutely we blocked 14
million port there are packets you know
today or whatever and and that's a
functionality that's been lost in the
cloud for quite some time and and now it
helps me rest a little easier because we
have more of a defendable posture when
we talk to our customers and to auditors
and and it helps us just convey the
message and be more more transparent I
think with how we're protecting the data
know that that's great thanks thanks
Jason for expanding on that and you were
also mentioning in during one of our
studies that you know when we were
actually coming and talking to you about
some of these products like network
details VPC flow logs and others you're
like do I need to use them and then like
slowly you you started using them and
now you can't lift about them it's
interesting to me that I grew up on Prem
right and and I used to implement
firewalls and built servers and network
and everything and there's tools you
don't realize you need and there's tools
that that you sort of say you take for
granted and you're you you you start out
in the cloud there's a lot of energy and
enthusiasm and then you're like yeah it
just works right but then you start to
really take it seriously you're like man
that's easier and it's so much better to
to have like instance level details if
we could do that on Prem or could have
back then it would have been amazing but
that's sort of the power of the cloud
right it allows you to to to build new
methods for solving old problems awesome
ok last but not the least I know that
when we have talked to you previously
you have been like a big advocate of
monitoring and and having visibility
into some of the metrics that Greg was
showing so the last use case we had is
like now your application is in
production and you have a HTTP load
balancer what tools are you using
currently to monitor and gain visibility
into traffic if you're using our tools
how are you using yeah no for sure I
appreciate that it's it's interesting we
as we move to micro services
architecture we we put a load balancer
in front of everything even if we don't
need to and we started doing that mainly
because we thought we don't know what we
don't know about our infrastructure
right and if we start putting a load
balancer we gain some of the like
stackdriver logging and things like that
but then also we get context for how our
traffic is working and what's
interesting always been interesting to
me is load balancing is is very very
much a ite sort of operations Network
problem but you gain situational
awareness of your environment of context
for how your traffic is actually shaping
so it's been interesting for us to put
load balancers in front of everything so
we can start to visualize the traffic
but then also understand it and
understand how our customers are using
it and as Greg showed you know maybe
maybe we forgot to set up logging it
never happens guys trust me but maybe we
forgot to set up logging and we didn't
know our north-america servers were down
or West Coast or East Coast servers were
down and now by visualizing it in
stackdriver we can see how man we're
routing to the wrong place we're
creating a problem for our customers
it's adding latency where it's not
necessary so we like the dashboard it
inside of stackdriver we do use another
tool I think it's called sumo logic to
do a lot of our visualization Morpher
dashboarding sake but my team
predominantly uses stackdriver when they
want to really get in to the
nitty-gritty of what's happening in the
infrastructure that's great thank you
Jason anything else that you would like
to add that you know some of these use
cases we talked about maybe some other
stuff that we've not mentioned and you
would like to mention yeah you know if I
could shameless plug some things where
we do take cybersecurity really security
really seriously at pivot and we're
really interested in helping protect our
customers data and the data around their
assets so we use a lot of tools to
protect all of the like core
functionality out of the cloud like like
firewall logging and and bigquery and
things like that help us gain better
context into our environment well we
also use tools of the application layer
like Trend Micro's deep security I think
I saw a booth for them here it's a great
tool you guys should definitely check
out their booth but I think more than
anything I think I made a comment
earlier that it's interesting to me that
you guys create tools that we didn't
know we needed
and and I really appreciate that and I
know I've seen some Googlers in the
audience and and I guess I would say
thank you for for continuing to make my
job a little easier it's hard in IT
operations and network to to go get more
resources you know we want to hire more
developers and we want to hire people
who can make our products get them to
market quicker and that's good we need
that but what we really what I really
need is to make my job a little bit
easier so I appreciate the tools you
guys develop and listening to us and in
developing them for us thank you Jason
so I'm sure that you might have tons of
questions for Jason and Vanessa and Greg
but before we do that before we start
taking some questions and have an
interactive session I just wanted to
wrap up as I'm as we mentioned
throughout the talk we've done a number
of customer studies on-site visits
workshops design workshops etc so if I
see some familiar faces in the audience
but if we've not talked to you please do
reach out to us we would love to talk to
you either remote on-site whatever
however whatever is convenient for you
if we don't understand and know your
problems it's harder to solve those and
you know we've released some of these
products that Greg demo today network
interface details VPC flow logs firewall
logs and also load balancer telemetry so
check them out if you haven't yet and
please do remember there's a lot more
coming so you know stay up-to-date with
our blogs on on networking
[Music]